Hi everyone, it's Jerry. I have a nice attacking game out of the French Defense to share with
you. This is a game from the 2011 Aeroflot Open, on the white end Gata Kamsky, playing
against Ding Liren. We have a Classical French. E5 signals the Steinitz variation. There are
a lot of pins in this game. I've lost track of how many there are. There are a bunch of
others that are right around the corner from happening in this one. If you happen to be
a teacher trying to emphasize pins to one of your students, this is an excellent game.
That's really the one tactic that sticks out. Anyhow, pins aside, where do we go from here?
These next several moves are going to be centered around white center. White will support these
pawns and black will try to undermine white's center. So as I play through these moves, you
may be curious about the strength of the players for this game. Kamsky, rated 2730, and the
18-year-old Ding Liren, rated 2628. It would only be less than two years before Ding Liren
would finally crack 2700 himself. So here we are, nine moves in, nearly maximum attention
on these two points. From here it is g3. Before viewing this game, when I saw g3, I didn't
think much about it beyond, oh, white's preparing to fianchetto. But after viewing this game, I
see things a bit differently. Now, once f6 is in, e6 is sensitive, so don't sleep on
bishop h3 as a move. Also, take note of this knight. It's now unprotected. As play sharpens,
we're going to see that these details matter. From here, queen b6, some attack and defense
of b2. Tension is released on e5. White is in no position now to take towards the center.
The knight hangs. Also, not a great idea here, not the best idea for white to take with the
knight because we would be exchanging, white would be exchanging his third-ranked knight
for black's second-ranked knight. And this guy is happy, has at least a legal move now.
So in the game it is d takes e5. And with that, we have a shift with the structure.
Got an extra pawn for black on the queenside. Rook d8, supporting a d4 advance. In comes
bishop h3, pop quiz. How would you respond to white's last move? Feel free to pause the video.
Okay, Ding Liren says, go ahead, take that pawn. Plays in the center. This guy on e6 is poison.
So in the game, bishop f2 is played. What's the story if white takes this pawn and says,
check. How is it that black is doing so well here? Well, now there would be more than one
problem for white to solve. Still have to do something about the bishop on e3. And this guy
on e6, the other bishop, is on a vulnerable square. It's tactically vulnerable. So if now
white backs off, for instance, there is knight d takes e5. Two problems. Bishop is hit, and the
unprotected knight on f3 is hit. Watch out. There might be a fork. Knight takes knight,
bishop takes bishop. This is considered a winning position for black. The bishop also is there just
in time to stop a follow-up fork. If I had to guess, if this game played out from here,
the piece that's going to walk away from this game with the MVP, this guy here, the unopposed
light square bishop. Look at all of these light square holes in white's camp. Alright. In this
game, the bishop goes back to f2 straight away. If you're wondering why doesn't white maybe first
capture on d4? I believe black benefits a bit more with these pawns being exchanged. c5 does
open up for multiple pieces, and who knows, maybe bishop b4 can be a move. Bishop f2 in this game,
black continues to press with the d-pawn. Same story here. If the capture, there'd be two
problems. Vulnerable bishop, problem on e2. In the game, knight c1. Now black defends on e6 directly,
and from here b3 is played. Taking on d3, there's a problem. There's a pin. Now you wouldn't be able
to take advantage of it straight away with c3 because there's also a pin here. But what black
can play is queen a6, and now next up there's c4, and the pinned piece will soon be won. For instance,
bishop f1, c4, gonzo, knight. In this game, b3, queen a6. More than one thing happening with this
move. I think it's a good idea to think about more than one thing with a queen move, the multi-purpose
piece. What's happening? Direct defense of the pawn gets out of the way of the b-pawn so it can
advance, so the bishop can develop, and there's also another pin. The rook is unprotected on a1.
We see this after a4, black can play b5. Don't take, you lose the rook. From here, castles, and now
bishop b7. Is there a better diagonal for the light square bishop? White defends the rook and is now
ready to open the a-file. What black would like to get in is a connected passed pawn. So something like this,
but if you play c4 here, it gets broken down straight away. Capture on b5 and c4, this file opens up for
white. What is black's play then? He goes with b4. He's trying to carve out a square for the knight. Black would
love to see this capture. Knight gets into b4. It's just a bonus that it comes with tempo. The big thing here is
that the knight is stable, and the d-pawn really feels like a connected passed pawn now. So white plays with c4.
Knight a5 threatens the knight, restricts this knight as well. The knight is defended, and where do we go from here?
What would be your plan? What would be your next move or two in this position? Feel free to pause the video.
Okay, in this game we have knight takes c4, a knight sacrifice for two pawns. You know, when I made my first pass or two
through this game, I did think to myself, yeah, that's a sacrifice, but I'm not so sure it's a sacrifice. The more I look at it,
it's not that great of an imbalance when you factor in that these guys are now all passed. So you've given up a knight.
You have two pawns as compensation, but these aren't just any ordinary pawns. They're passed pawns, and there's added value there.
From here, f5, black takes. If you don't take, f6 can be a disruptive move to your king position. He takes. Is okay inviting the bishop
on this pawn. Queen d5, bishop takes d3, and c4. There is a pin here on this knight on f3, don't go too far.
The queen gets to h1, and then h2. Kingside is going to collapse in a blink if the f3 knight moves. Bishop b1, black keeps the queens on.
Queen is hit. She goes to e1, clears the way for the rook to contribute. Now knight g6. What's considered best here for white is to
capture the knight, not the move played. It's a pretty difficult decision for white to make here. I think this bishop feels like it's at least
going to be a very important defender of these connected passed pawns. This knight is on this pawn. In the game, rook f2 is played,
and black is able to simply take on e5. What if white tries something else? Let's say white doesn't want to go for bishop takes knight,
and instead tries to defend e5. Bishop f2 would hang the knight. If bishop f4, how can you continue? It likes bishop c5 check.
The king then goes straight into a pin. The knight would be in an absolute pin. Then white, excuse me, black can pile up on the light square bishop,
get the rooks on the f and e files. In this one, it is simply the doubling of the rooks. The pawn is picked up. Now it's an instant mate if the knight moves.
From here, knight e2, and now a very nice move, rook to d3. This isn't considered best, but it's definitely the flashiest. I like the immediate
pressure it exerts on white's camp. It targets this unprotected bishop, rook d3. What is considered best, bishop f6, and then start rolling with the
pawns. Bishop does x-ray the c3 square once you play b3, c3 is a hole. That's the plan here in the computer's eyes. In this game, rook d3, knight on e to d4,
queen d5. This guy is still pinned. In comes bishop takes rook. This is now considered winning for team black. What's considered best? The suggestion is to go with
these slow moves for white. That is h3, and then king to h2. Reason for these moves? Well, this pinned knight would finally be able to move. Once the king is on h2,
at least this square is covered. Okay, in this game, bishop takes rook, knight takes bishop. Okay, we get the exchange right back. There is still a pin on the
knight. From here, activate the rook. It's the only piece that wasn't contributing. In comes h4, c3, queen d3. Both knights are now pinned. Move f3, it's mate. Move this knight, you lose the queen.
Bishop c5 doesn't really get much better than this. Bishops on adjacent diagonals, both bearing down towards the kingside. Bishop f4. You can't improve the queen or the bishops. From here, it's all about finding a great square for the rook.
Piles up on the pinned knight. Bishop e5, rook e8, threatening to take. Bishop goes back. Rook check, poison rook, mate on h1 if you take. White goes into a self-pin, and now queen takes knight is available.
The knight on d4 is pinned. There's two pins straight to the king because of this last move. Rook is pinned, and now the knight on d4 is pinned. And the knight on f3 is pinned. Okay, in the game, queen takes queen. Bishop takes knight. At this stage, white has finally had enough of the pins, I'm guessing, and simply threw in the towel.
If play continued, how might it look? King h2, you take the queen. You're okay in this position because these guys are way too good. Playing out just a few more moves, if there's a check, rook b8, they simply push right through. There's no stopping them.
What did you think of this one? Anyhow, feel free, as usual, to leave any feedback to this video in the comments section below. I hope you enjoyed it, and maybe took a thing or two away. That's all for now. Take care. Bye.